Hình sẽ thích hình sẽ công an thành phố cần thơ danh thủ liy, điều tra vụ an cức dật tại sản sĩ trang ngày
tắm tháng 3 năm 2020 tại công ty tân hơi viên thuộc ấp phủng hiệp, sả an ninh
thành phố cần thơ. Ngày hai người ta tháng 3 năm 2020, coi quan cạnh sát điều tra công an thành phố
cần thơ ra quyết định quy tìm người đối với mối bố cá nhân sau đây.
Một nguyễn thi hoa, sinh năm 2020, người thường tụ khóng cho thử một phường châu đất,
tỉnh An Giang. 2 nguyễn văn nghĩa, sinh năm 2020, đầy thường chức phố năm
thường dật giá, tỉnh An Giang. 3 tâu phang vẽ mới, sinh năm 2020, người thường tụ
ốc tù khu hài, sả định Mỹ, tỉnh An Giang. 4 nguyễn thi nghĩa, sinh năm 2020,
người thường tụ ốc tên thành, sả tên lông, tỉnh đồng thấp.
5 sau phần đất, sinh năm 2020, đầy thường tụ phường dật giá, tỉnh An Giang.
6 nguyễn văn lên, sinh năm 2020, đầy thường tụ khóng cho thử một phường châu đất, tỉnh An Giang.
8 lời mình sân, sinh năm 2020, đầy thường tụ phường dật giá, tỉnh An Giang.
8 hồ thị thân tuyền, sinh năm 2020, đầy thường tụ khu hợp bẩy, phường gái khế,
hành phố cần thơ. 9 lời mình chăm, sinh năm 2020, đầy thường tụ phường dật giá, tỉnh An Giang.
4 nguyễn ngọc mình, sinh năm 2020, đầy thường tụ ốc khám ngàn, sả Mỹ đất, tỉnh An Giang.
7 nguyễn văn trường dàng An, sinh năm 2020, đầy thường tụ ốc tỉnh Thành, sả tinh lâu, tỉnh Đồng Thật.
7 nguyễn thị dính, sinh năm 2020, đầy thường tụ, không cho ốc khám, phường dật giá, tỉnh An Giang.
7 nguyễn văn trứng, sinh năm 2020, đầy thường tụ ốc Anh hư, giá, tỉnh An Giang.
7 nguyễn thị dính, sinh năm 2020, đầy thường tụ, phường lâu xuân, tỉnh An Giang.
Các cánh dừng đâu cho mình không được đầy thần ở đâu, cần tụi chức đi tìm đất u diếu cháu ánh a nhìn dừng.
Đức đó, ngày 2021 đầy thantea năm 2020, không trong 2016 tưởng nguyễn văn thân, sinh năm 2020,
1 íν trính giảm tám miền hai khường tụi tại khoống tr SEO thứ 1, cùng trâu đốc, tĩnh Anh Giang đã chào tạo tụi để được phủ mứng sử khoan hòng thật hấp được.
Để tạo điều kiện trong 18 toi được hướng chính sách khoan hồm, s pork có cơ hội gồi nguàng tụi với gia đình và hoàn nhập với còn đông.
Cô quan cạnh sát điều tra, phần cạnh sát hình sự, công an thành phố cần thơ kêu gọi người phòng tồi đang lẫn trúng hãy nhìn chóng trái đầu thú, để nghỉ gia đình người thân của người phòng tồi, các cơ quan, tổ chức, cạnh dân và các cấp chính quyền tạo ngoài điều kiện thường lời, tích cực giáo dục, phí phục, đồng viên, giúp đợi đánh người phòng tồi trái đầu thú.
Tuy tình trường hợp cù thế thơ quy định của pháp luật người phòng tổ chá đầu thú có thể được xem sẽ cho phải ngoài, mẹn kuy cữ chấp nhìn hình sự, mẹn, giảm nhẹn phạt, giảm án.
Hình này đã có nhiều đối tưởng từ chá trà đầu thú, khác phục hồ quả, và các cấp pháp luật tổ chá đều tra để lập công trục tồi.
Đây là cơ hồ tốt đến người phòng tổ chá phục lỗi lắm, ăn năng, khối cải, và nổ chá đình, đối về hoàn nhập với cộng đồng, làm ăn lưng thình, chất thành người gọi chá đình và sá hội, không còn phải trốn tránh, loa sạo vì vác.
Nụk lại đến người phòng tổ y tích tục lẫn trúng mà thực hiện hành vi phòng pháp luật khi vắt được sẽ bị sự liên nhìn khác.
A, chế chấp phật biết mà không tổ chá sầu phẩm khi tui tính chất, mất đầu vì sự liên khơi trình pháp luật.
Nguyên đầu thú có thể trực tích đến trình dình, gọi điên phải, thông quan người thương liên hệ với cơ quan cảnh sát điều tra, phòng cảnh sắc hình sự, công ngàn thành phố cần thơ, đi chỉ, số 1 trăm tảm đám đám, 1 mũi văn cử, 1 kái kế, thành phố cần thơ hoặc cho đổi trực tiếp với điều tra vinh trình phí hùng, số điên phải, không chính 1 tảm năm năm, không bũm bũm bũm để được khứng dẫn.